the Joe Rogan experience you know what's
the craziest story unboxing in the years
Errol sprint junior surviving that
[ __ ] Ferrari crash that's the
craziest story of the year when you see
that car flip like that and the fact
that he got out up with like a chipped
tooth
I mean it's bonkers thank God he didn't
have a seatbelt on I never say that
thank God he didn't have a [ __ ] seat
belt on because if he did there's no way
he would be dead probably or [ __ ]
severely injured you know yeah yeah and
you know I was in Chicago and it was the
you sick fight that that week when that
happen and it was one of those things
where it reminded me when I first heard
the news of Paul Williams yes and you
realize like yo yeah these guys are
warriors they put their life on the line
like people died in the ring and all
that [ __ ] but there's also real life too
like there's a whole other life with all
its dangers
and all the other ways that people can
meet tragedy and hurdles you have to
overcome and that's the point to put to
you almost want to keep them sheltered
in a box between fights so that nothing
happens nothing can taint what's going
to happen in the ring but these guys are
just like everybody else to that degree
lakeshore you know I mean he's rich he's
you know in this town where he grew up
and one night you make a bad decision
changes everything yeah
and so now until we seem in the ring
again we don't know how that affects him
you just can't you can't know if we'll
ever see the arrow spins that we saw
before hopefully we do and better how
badly was he injured from what I
understood and I follow this very
closely not badly at all like you're not
wrong like he from what I understand he
had issues like teeth being knocked out
lacerations on his face no broken bones
no concussion no can come here I don't
know no everybody had no concussion we
had no serious brain injury he had no
permanent injury whatsoever that's crazy
but the mental side of it is that to
each individual to handle to be faced
with death like that right that age like
it's whatever the moment was when you
were flying through the air not knowing
if you're going to live right you don't
know how people you don't know how
people adjust to that it's so bad
because him and Crawford god damn what a
fight that would be yeah god damn that
is the fight it's almost like our wish
loma chenko was taller you know what she
was a bigger fighter you know like cuz
lomachenko versus Crawford was really
the fight that I would want to see
because those I mean I believe arrow
Spence jr. is right there with them he's
phenomenal fighter particularly what he
did with Garcia but lomachenko and turns
Crawford the two masters when I look at
them in terms of what they do to their
opponents they're the - no match anchor
with that crazy movement and footwork
it's but Terence Crawford just figures
people out he finds a way he switches
stances he'll start out southpaw or
started out Orthodox then they'll switch
up on you and start box and you know he
puts all the data into that computer and
then starts finding your weaknesses and
then he gets nasty with you and I love
the I mean one of things I like about
him is how [ __ ] Meany is you know the
other guy is like a sweetheart the
nicest guy I'm in here right I mean he
was great he was a great podcast guest
but once he starts putting it on dudes
man there's like a meanness to him you
know it's like you see he relishes in it
when the dudes go down he gets a kick
out of it yeah yeah yeah there's that
killer instinct oh but these Heights
there's no replacement for them you can
see Terence in a great fight you can see
loma drink on a great fight space a
great fight but if they're not fighting
each other right we just won't know
because once you get to an elite level
everybody's so good you can't say you
know how this is gonna turn on it right
right and so loma Chango is too small I
mean I don't think he's ever gonna fight
Terence I mean there was a time when the
Mikey Garcia fight could have happened
with Loma chenko and 35 I don't think he
should ever fight a 40 or a but I mean
he'd say that same but when you see what
Mikey Garcia would happen to him when he
went up again arrows fence you see gogo
Errol's is way bigger and stronger and
better yeah he's just 247 pounds of
vision
yeah and he's jacked arrow Spencer's
just jacked at 47 like ripped and
shredded and at the weigh-in when I
looked at two miles like wow that's a
desert difference right little
difference there again by the time fight
night is fight night song fight a little
way Errol's yeah arrows even bigger I
think him and hopefully he's okay
hopefully he's okay and he said he's
getting back to the gym and getting back
after it him and Terrence is they'll
fight that is the face of fighters gotta
happen it's got out and no neither one
of them fighting anybody else will tell
us more about what's gonna happen when
they fight each other arrow Spence is
back in training right he's training yes
yeah and has been for a while that's
what the reports say so are they trying
to make something happen soon is there
an idea of like I believe I think he's
thinking like may like really that's
again you know talk and he's the kind of
guy that's gonna want to jump right back
into the deep water I don't think he's a
tune-up fight type of dude no not after
the Garcia fight I'd like to see that
one live that's when I might I might go
to see that one live yeah or something
or MGM I might flying to see that one
that was that's a very very very
interesting fight to me
[Applause]